hello and welcome everyone thank you for
joining us for today's webinar the role
of endosomes and prostate cancer
presented by dr. Ian Johnson research
fellow University of South Australia I'm
Christie Joel of lab routes and I will
be moderating today's session we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
Rhodes is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
today's event is sponsored by KidCo by
thermo Fisher to learn more about our
sponsor please visit thermo Fisher com
forward slash cell culture heroes before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen type in your
questions into the drop down box and
click send if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the ask a question box to let us know
you're experiencing a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits our speaker today is dr. Ian
Johnson dr. Johnson is a leading
molecular cell biologist in prostate
cancer focusing his research efforts on
endosome lysis on biology in this
disease with the seminal discovery of
altered endosomal biogenesis in prostate
cancer for a complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen now without
further ado please join me in welcoming
dr. Johnson I will now turn the
presentation over to him
Thank You Christy for the introduction
and thank you sir moat and give Co Chile
opportunity to say to talk to you about
the role of endosomes in prostate cancer
and the work I've been doing this area
I'm p.m. I'm a research fellow down in
the mechanisms in south island diseases
research group which is part of the
University of South Australia School of
Pharmacy and Medical Sciences this group
is headed by professor Doug Brooks we're
based in the new University South
Australia Cancer Research Institute
which is part of the Adelaide biomedical
precinct that composes the new Royal
Adelaide Hospital the SA Health and
Medical Research Institute the
University of Adelaide Health and
Medical Sciences Building and our own
cry importantly for the cricket lovers
out there we get a great view of the
Adelaide Oval and occasionally see a few
always it's mold since we've know how it
got the diverse audience today I'm going
to briefly give you an overview to the
prostate and then some background into
end zone biology I'll then take you into
the work that we've done characterizing
prospect cell lines the seminal
discovery of all defenders I'm
biogenesis and the involvement of
enzymes in other aspects of prostate
cancer biology such as in reactive
oxygen species production
the prostate is this walnut-sized gland
that's got an outer shell or capsule and
within which we find fibromuscular
stroma and the transitional central and
peripheral zones
situated beneath the bladder which year
the recent past is through and as we
know if we have a benign or malignant
growth of prostate this can impact your
it bladder control quite significantly
secretary epithelial cells arise from
these stem cells that differentiate into
transit amplifying cells so there are
other types of cells such as the basal
neuroendocrine and stromal cells but
primarily prostate cancer prostate
cancer pathogenesis initiates from
security of epithelial cells and they
look normally something like this so if
I say cancer in Australia
more than 17,000 men are diagnosed with
the disease every year that represents
more than 28% of newly diagnosed cases
each year there are more than three and
a half thousand deaths that represents
$0.12 of all cancers and it's the second
most common cause of cancer related
deaths second only to lung cancer
globally more than a million are
diagnosed every year and there are over
300 thousands deaths and we can see on
the graph on the right for incidence and
mortality are strongly linked with age
but incidence really occurring in men
over the age of 40
the turnstile standard for prostate
cancer diagnosis is the PSA blood test
that tests for the protein prostate
specific antigen or Cal occurring 3 and
the problem with this test is that it
son specific it could be elevated due to
benign enlargements such as the benign
prostate hyperplasia or due to
infections such as prostatitis or unique
tract infections and indeed inflammation
a more precise method of testing is the
digital rectal examination and this is
not recommended other routine tests if
it is performed it should be performed
by an expert urologist and only
complement high PSA blood test so this
is where the aromas will palpate the
gland and attempt to detect any
hardening swelling or surface lumps
problem is these weren't necessarily
indicate because there is a tumor and so
further investigation such as biopsies
are always required
these methods there are too many both
negative or false positive results you
cannot determine how severe a malignancy
is and treating them as well can often
cause greater mobility than living with
a disease as such current guidelines
don't recommend the population screening
program there are other tents and
markers for example C reactive protein
can be used for prostate cancer however
this has other malignant associations as
colorectal ovarian cancer and of course
many banana procreation where that
inflammation or as a result of injury or
infection or cardiovascular disease
see a 15-3 Z and 99 also have relations
to prostate cancer however again these
are not specific to the disease as such
there is a more specific need for more
sensitive and specific diagnostic and
prognostic markers
so historically there's evidence of an
increase in in lysosomal expression like
some more changes in cancer
search capacity can actually be used
potentially as a marker for breast
cancer metastasis they've seen acids
Aram 'days is upregulated in prostate
cancer and that confers oncogenic
phenotypes and also we've got concepts
in B which has higher 50 on the exterior
face of tumor these hydro lasers are
found within Muslims and lysosomes these
membrane bound organelles with a pH of
about 4.5 and that's important because
that regulates the enzyme activity
lysosomes are also critical for similar
degradation
Palestra homeostasis and all tofurkey
the release of these lysosome enzyme can
also trigger apoptosis so the lines of
those are membrane bound organelles and
they're part of the N design licensing
system and that is the primary interface
for contact between the intracellular
and extra environments they're
controlled secretion of biological
molecules and through the Provisionals
membrane material they're essential to
cell division and proliferation
intracellular signaling
and of course don't I know means static
as we can see here in this video over a
couple of minutes
so the diagnosis of endosomes and
lysosomes is defined as the synthesis
tool organization of structural elements
of the end design system to form an
integrated set of functional organelles
genell's are involved in the by
synthetic or in acidic pathways the bio
synthetic meaning vesicular traffic from
the endoplasmic reticulum oncology
towards the distal elements of enzyme
Network and that includes the early
latent endosomes and lost multi
particular bodies and we also have the
endocytic pathway and that involves
memory transport from the cell surface
through to early recycling and late
endosomes failure taken through a basic
transistor stuff now and some of the
critical machinery required which we'll
be revisiting later
so here it is a very average cell we
have our plasma membrane and we have
these membrane bound receptors as we
follow these receptors
such as transfer lines and that induces
a change such as phosphorylation that
phosphorylation event enables rad52 bind
we've also has clattering forming this
clustering coated pit that creates this
empathetic vesicle we just saw the
association of two protectors Apple one
and Apple two they bind to Rab five and
we can define this vesicle by the
presence of these masters deserve was
known as a pre ender zone
ligand bound receptor we can essentially
have signaling from this compartments as
well
po3 pee in
Association of Apple and Apple - and
provides a dining site for another
protein called early endosome
answer one or eat a 1 so this
compartment is now matures into unfairly
endosome we just will dissociation of a
ligand from a receptor that's because
this n dalian zone is slightly acidic
and specific cargo that distance for
this compartment will dissociate
for the biosynthetic pathway
from the Golgi we have membrane-bound
receptors hear that Dino respected cargo
for example we have magnetic phosphate
receptors binding lysosomal hydrogen or
live to finding vehicle silos
they signaling motifs on this side a
classic tale induced they're trafficking
to their relevant departments and they
travel through the early endosome
other material such as the color creams
of which PSA is one of those we'll head
to the recycling in zone which we'll
come to later so the only undertone
matures into a late endosome through
this rad five rap seven switch so you
can define late endosomes by AB seven
again it's slightly more acidic and so
we have further dissociation of specific
cargo from their receptors it's
interesting we have lived to hear as
well and minsu is a clinical regulator
of biogenesis of venice ohms and when
it's over Express can actually result in
swollen compartments and impair
trafficking
we also have other machinery here such
as the escort proteins and these caused
the invitational outward burning
vesicles from the lenders own this
traffics material back to the golgi for
example the investigation of the
membrane creates these intraluminal
vesicles and the compartments known as
the multiphysics in the body or MVB
and if that MVP fuses with a plasma
membrane these intraluminal vesicles
will be released and that's what are
termed exosomes finally we have the
lysosome this is the highly acidic
compartment and this will fuse with the
Latin Simon reform for cargo delivery or
the most secular body will fuse for the
lysosome either way many proteins are
degraded in this compartment
we also have the recycling in zone which
is a critical organelle for the
recycling of plasma membrane receptors
back to the plasma membrane
zone is defined by rav4 for fast
recipients and Rab 11:4 floras I've
handsome and we see here the receptors
have traffic's back to the cell surface
so we have it a relatively simple sized
model of the N design polite slow
Network and some of the critical
proteins involved
your hypothesis was that lies level
function will be altered in prostate
cancer and that this might result in the
release of licensing from profit Kent
sells all of your markers the fitted
safe early detection
we start off investigating many of those
prostate cancer cell lines that are
available that's because only a limited
number are often used in literature
particularly with the non malignant
cells so the variability validity of
this model is not established
to be honest it is a method
pain-in-the-ass dealing with Sony so
line particularly with a doubt such
requirements but plenty good coke at
least inventing wise next brothel as an
angle
so we analyzed bunch of lifestyle
proteins and genes such as acid rants
around Basin of acceptance B and D and
it was quite interesting because it
shows that the commonly used rw1
normalling that cell line actually have
significant elevate significantly
elevated expression all these lysosomal
genes and protein especially of
transcription factor e B or T cells down
the bottom right and that's important
because that's actually a master
regulator of license during the
biogenesis
other than p1 and c eh hpz ten which an
account stolen actually showed very
similar phenotypes in the protein
processing and expression of a lot of
things gene and proteins so we think
that there are some other facts
resulting from that hex procedure
inspection the other long line itself
PN C 1 a and P 2 are a transformed sv40
and didn't display these same
characteristics
the intracellular protein expression has
found that there's a wide variation in
these cells and there's certainly
nothing striking however when we looked
at the secrete ohm
we found that the cancer cell lines have
enough regulation of some of these
concepts of B and acids or M days which
previously been alluded to what's
interesting is that we saw that the
connecting D didn't have much effect
indeed didn't have much change but
mature peasant beads is this rather
overall expression not really being
different between the two there's
actually suggested that maybe these were
being released from an endo zone
location that's because they mature in a
slightly different way and a slightly
more basic pH than the lysosome
of course we also analyzed the cells by
confocal fluorescence and we found that
lysosomes do have a change in
distribution in the normal ignorant
cells into one and pt.2 we get this
pairing nuclear localization and in our
cancer cells we get this wide dispersal
of para cellular lamp one particularly
out to the periphery
so there's no you that lifts here is a
pretty
our chances and we found that with
elevators between two and four polls in
both gene and protein expression is in
cancer cell lines versus non Venegas
that's interesting because
overexpression can actually disrupt
trafficking through the endosomal system
so he postulated that the biogenesis
have endosomes but not low Soames was
affected in prostate cancer well gee
there's a fundamental change in
herbology event zones in these cells
so we investigated some of these early
and their mothers but proved solidity
I firstly discussed limp - was
upregulated but also Apple one Apple to
read 5a + e EA one which are all part of
this early endosome system also saw
upregulated rap for but we did not see
any change in these Latin zone Rab 7 or
the licen lamp one gene and protein
expression
importantly these changes were observed
in microarray cohorts and we saw that
the expression was increased either in
primary cancel or decrease in metastatic
cancer so there's some dysfunction
deregulation happening here what this
essentially is if you combine after one
wrap five of ei1 gene expression Basin
predicts cancer recurrence so these are
patients that have had counselor
prostate cancer and when you divide them
by K means clustering into high or low
gene expression groups for these three
genes we see that high expression
potentially results in greater chance of
relapse
the sense micro raschel mort's a bit
hit-and-miss playing or eerily performs
and how many samples are processed it
was important to measure them by
qPCR so we obtain fresh frozen samples
from the pcrc by Bank in Dublin Ireland
and then we carefully cuts H&E stains
and then specify expert pathologist John
O'Leary attends college and the
approximate location of the cancer
tissue was noted and a rough dissection
was performed followed by RNA extraction
so it finally despite the very rusty
section happening the changes of gene
expression Apple run revived and ei1 or
big enough to overcome that pollution of
cat cells with normal cells
so we want to know what in the sample
processes might be posted in prostate
cancer that could affect the pub's
Genesis return to our cell lines we know
that much like lysosome early endosomes
are also missed positions and here an
example of ei 130 enzyme antigen one
where again see perinuclear localization
of early endosomes in the non Ling
themselves and in the ten cells we see
greater parry solar distribution of
these components especially we can
measure the differences that this might
create and that is using for example
ligands uptake in this case transferring
we're transferring binds these
transferring receptors and get up taken
over period of time and delivered to
their final organelle which is the Golgi
so the normalling cells on the Left we
see over the period of half an hour that
these this transfer which is in white
migrates to this perinuclear region and
in our cancer cells they remain
dispersed throughout particularly at
these at the tips of the cells
that actually affects the signaling as
well so we can use akt phosphorylation
as a measure of this signaling and we
see that PT 1 am these two non malignant
cells have a regular date a 54,000 as
you'd expect however that appears to be
quite these functional deregulated in
the cancer cells in fact we're 2012 e1
we didn't detect any fossil ocean at all
conclusion from this was the ultimate
origin system insulin function is that
the ends advisor sorry and in function
is also in prostate cancer as a result
of the unregulated enzyme machinery the
altered location often designs the live
sperms and this disturb trafficking and
signaling so it's a potential new avenue
for investigation to the developer
markers that may aid diagnosis and
prognosis
so
we'll now move on to other aspects of
enzyme biology that are affecting the
prostate cancer and that's for example
there Jeff signaling and this is work
done by Ian Harrison with about Knox to
oxidase
so veg f ligginz uptake by ZF receptor
to the receptor undergoes restarting
through the early enzymes the recycling
ends at Baxter plasma membrane and it
requires this internalization
in order to actually perform its
signaling if we delay there Jeff
receptor enzyme trafficking we end up
with dephosphorylation receptor
deactivation and decreased arterial
morphogenesis
interestingly veg F stimulates
production of reactive oxygen species
such as super oxide and hydrogen
peroxide these can promote cell
proliferation and angiogenesis and
they're highly reactive they're
generated by these NADPH oxidizers or
NOx enzymes
one of these is knocks two and knocks
two resides on these early endosomes so
we investigated whether endosomal knocks
has any influence or alterations in
prostate cancer and we found that yes
they do tests of all we see we're not so
that primary cancer has elevated
expression of not too
knocks for we see quite an elevation in
metastatic tissue
using our faucet samples from Islands we
also saw the impressive tissue not for
was significantly up regulated
using a synergetic model of prostate
cancer in mice when we delete Knox -
that actually decreases angiogenesis and
prostate tumors and that's also the same
when we inhibit Knox to oxidize
pharmacologically so on the right here
we can see a decrease in CCD 31 positive
cells and a reduction in bed if r2
positive cells in the Knox to knock down
there Jeff receptor internalizes into
early end of them we see here IEA one
co-localize e with by Jeff receptor 2
but when we inhibit that uptake using
dinosaur and pit stop that inhibits
endocytosis of receptors through
resonance we saw a decrease in that
colocation
so we can measure the capacity suggest
stimulate superoxide production
and we found that the superoxide
increases that's red green that
increases 38 with 13 anagrams and
hundred milligrams per mil of HF ligand
this happens over time between north and
30 minutes we can see here through the
time course that the superoxide
production in pieces that's likely as
the edge of ligand enters these Enders
and apartments
we also see that when we knock out locks
to super oxide production is
significantly reduced
not to co-localize errs not much with
everyone
and not a great deal with EA one but we
see a significant colocation of NOx to
the be stratified endosomes
it's also important to note that end of
our pH is important for superoxide
production when we treat with the filler
myosin which inhibits the vacuolar z TPA
which mediates and so muslim'
anticipation we end up with a neutral
neutralized ends level pH and that's a
significant lead images superoxide
production
so summary here we saw that not sorts
plays expressed in innocence promote
prostitution developments
when we knock it out it reduces down is
Genesis so we think that ultra dense
learn by Genesis may affect Ross
production and the downstream events
increase the expression of the soaring
cancer is allowed Lee to elevate
reproduction
moving on that was it some work formed
by Heather Armstrong on investigating
hsp90 inhibitors these are second gen
inhibitors and this is an interesting
work on fibronectin and cytoskeletal
changes
so Hector's been nicely is the molecular
chaperone with ATPase ATPase activity
it regulates the stabilization
maturation and activation of over 200
other proteins otherwise known as
clients and that's an important target
in prostate cancer therapy especially
due to its involvement with antrum
receptor shown there on the left
learning of client proteins and driven
by the binding and hydrolysis of ATP
which results in the release of mature
clients on the right there are many more
of these conquer these clients otherwise
no longer produce
so now only it's actually nicely
important in testosterone activation of
antigen receptor but also in the signal
transduction of membrane receptors such
as receptor tyrosine kinase on the right
here
and that's important because they are
can still be activated is in
castrate-resistant prostate cancer
so if we can inhibit hey speak nicely we
are ultimately can inhibit these
pathways and oncogenic effects
so the inhibitors act by blocking the
binding of ATP to the heat shock protein
and that enables the clients to actually
type statistic aggravation
you
well this ring was the hsp90 inhibitor a
192 actually affects fibronectin
expression it increases in response to
the drug
selection is associated with the
excellent matrix and since its secreted
the combines of Instagram to bind the
cell khanjan extra Lemaitre
interestingly not only does the
inhibitor increased our tanks and gene
expression from French expression
it also reduces its secretion
this is an example of just what five
minutes it would do by saline screen and
then to the ecology
so we see this secreted fibronectin
but is inhibited
that's interesting because it also
increased the apoptosis cells and
decrease their prolific potential
so with this we also saw increased
density of fibrinogen staining in cells
as shown here
and these were in these punctate
compartments
which we saw as early and late endosomes
this colocation is in white
we don't see any accumulation in
lysosomes where it would be degraded so
the method of secretion may well be from
these multicolored bodies or early
endosomes
and that makes sense since our
connection has been seen in extra silly
physical released from prostate cancer
cell lines and in the plasma and urine
from clinical patients
trafficking to the plasma membrane is
dependent on market ribble Association
persons and there are several of these
which are known clients approach p90 and
the interesting thing in that we saw a
reduction of myosin expression in
response to HB 90 inhibitor just could
well be what's trafficking 5 mentioned
out of the cell
and the model there's something like
this we have our Haiti to being 90 and
microtubules and the five minutes in
being traffic's vary by meiting along is
like the tubules things created
with the inhibitor
the mic retriever was no longer there or
at least the motor is no longer there's
traffic these compartments so the FO
connection just fills up in these early
or multi sit to the body compartments
summary here we solve a 102 of the cell
structure through inhibition rate regime
19 which the reduction the expression of
my frugal proteins reduction enzyme
trafficking and reduction in secretion
of this as x2 the matrix protein
fibronectin that will inhibit the cell
to communicate or attach the surrounding
tissue and it increases cell death and
reduces proliferation
so frantically raise submerse that has
just been submitted for publication on a
and NSM of protein including ten-in-one
and sincerely whatever is critical for
exercise biogenesis in those multi
particular bodies you've seen earlier
it's a crystal adapter protein that can
affect so little membrane organization
cell adhesion protein trafficking and
activation of transcription factors
so you know things lots like this with
commercial antibodies that we buy and it
doesn't matter what blocking condition
to use or how you treat the cells you
cannot get a specific band and you
cannot determine the expression of the
protein
so these develops spatially distinct
epitopes to unique linear sequences on
since nm1 and these are unique to the
six or seven amino acid level meaning
unlikely that their antibody will bind
to other proteins
then plead the tips that we've targeted
keep these beautiful clean western blots
and when we knock helps in tenon we see
the reduction as expected
so these antibodies are specific what
interesting is that we can use these two
spatially distinct antibodies together
in analyzer so we can capture sin 10 in
one using one antibody and detectives
with a biasing related sin sin and
antibody coming in on top
but when we look at these with an
inflorescence we're taught from striking
differences well as clinical Emma's own
poster highlighted by our to see six
episode about the three a eleven
highlight thinks microtubules and that's
really interesting it's not
well that isn't scintillant we certainly
have seen evidence in a literature that
supports this hypothesis but it's a new
either form or variants depending
functional variants indeed here and an
area scanned image we see colocation of
beta-tubulin and our sin tenon 3a 11
episode
what's interesting is that we saw an
increase staining by
immunohistochemistry in prostate cancer
tissue using 311
with 2c6 we do not see so much standing
either nominal bleeding tissue
so we suggest that these new monoclonal
antibodies might highlight the multiple
functions and protein roles potential
roles of sin sin and one truth and those
further investigation is required so to
conclude we've seen today two
characterizing multiple prostate cell
lines both nominating and malignant but
HPV or mortalized cells might not be
suitable for studying the cell biology
of prostate cancer we've seen it's also
been designed by Genesis through the up
regulation of early endosome and gene
and protein expression and they also
vents own traffic that results
morphozine that know the cell biology
that's critical second discuss gender
whether it's ross production or
suppression of factors they all require
these endosomes and so the change in
enzyme biology may disrupt these
critical functions and promote
pathogenesis and we've just seen the
potential of a new Isis form of sin
tenant so that's a critical cofactor in
excellent biogenesis I want to thank the
teams at unirse when
in Florence Alexandra's silvina just
loading chassis Thomas Jeff Healey
thanks professor Lisa Butler Universidad
laid his PhD she was Heather on frog is
now at the University of Alberta Canada
staff calamitous Danna RMIT and
inheritance of work on the Knox proteins
John O'Leary and his team at Trinity
College Dublin and also professor bill
Watson who is the head of the pcrc
cohort family one Boniface inna at the
NIH along with dedication charlie and
also Roberto finally our funding which
is from a profit and Spanish from
Australia the Center for men's health
and the FA Cancer Council
thank you for listening there is much
more that can be discussed there's a lot
more work to be done you can find me at
any of these addresses and I'll now open
it up for questions
thank you
thank you dr. Johnson for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as
time permits okay dr. Johnson your first
question do you have any idea why the
rwp e1 and CA HPV 10 cell lines
performed so differently to the other
normal or cancer cell line
sure yep so we think that when these
normally cell lines have established
these abnormal phenotypes were
introduced through that fire of
transformation and that power of
transformation is recall required simply
to make these normal cells help yourself
keep rewriting but the other pp1 cell
expresses 6:37 anchor proteins and the
chp 310 expresses the e6 oncoprotein so
these are enabling cell cycle
progression to continue unimpeded but
they also stabilize accumulation of p53
and that's that's been shown to affect
lysosomal stability the sv40 cell lines
the Pinta one entity they only express
large tension and they lack a p53
stabilizing agent so that's one is that
difference there and thank you
okay thank you our next question can you
please expand on why cathepsins e and
acid - Rama days are secreted when other
life somal lice or syllables proteins
were not sure from memory doesn't be as
reported - many have an endosomal
location whereas capacity is more
lysosomal so these are processed in
these alternate compartments and the
same with acids Rama days
it's a matures in an endothermic rammons
and not the lysosomal compartment and it
also has acid Rama date has a specific
role in multicolor bodies so whilst a
seroma date is trafficked with magnetics
faucet receptor altered glycosylation
can change where this terminators
trafficked - so it can be diverted into
secretory vesicles so we're seeing
process of process form suggesting that
it is traffic to the enzymes but that
it's potentially being released either
in secretory vesicles or F or from these
particular bodies
Thanks
transferrin that showed different
distributions in cancer cells do you
know what endosome ZZZ words yeah I
didn't actually show these we did
perform collocation studies they were
more qualitative and constitutive the
same in the non malignant cells we had
clustering of transferring with
colocation transferring with limp 2 and
wrap 7 so this suggests that it's in the
late endosomes and those were near the
nucleus and in the camp cells we did see
some transferring with limb to but also
that the Golgi and the majority of the
transferring those cancer cells was in
the apple one rat 5 and ea1 compartments
that's where it's in to betray
localizing with those markers
Johnson now looks like we have time for
one more question have you investigated
whether androgen receptor expression or
androgen responds affect the expression
or biogenesis of men defense
sure so that's quite an important thing
for prostate cancer and particularly
since it's driven or the primary cancer
is driven by Antrim and hence why enter
into a profession therapies use so the
both side lines do Express higher
amounts of these endosomal markers than
then non-responsive cells or someone
responds itself but we're encouraged to
find that those the expression of those
genes was elevated in primary cancers
and it's perhaps why metastatic cancers
things return to normal or decrease so
they may very well be driven by and
responsible we haven't actually done any
specific studies on toads yet there is
some databases online where they have
done treatments I believe rap 5 is
upregulated
thank you again dr. Johnson no - how
many final comments from audience thank
you all for listening on this afternoon
or morning wherever you are you can
reach out to me on the media channels
that are on the screen I want to thank
again my collaborators and thank of
course give Kerr thermo Fisher for this
opportunity to speak and thank you
Christy for setting this up thank you
again dr. Johnson for your time today
and also for your important research we
would also educate collaborate yes and
our sponsor give Coe by thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast now before we go I
would like to thank the audience for
joining us today
and for their interesting questions
again questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast will be available for
viewing on demand laborat swill alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
this today's live event you will now be
redirected to the microsite where you
can register for our upcoming webinar
utilizing the lens epithelial explant
culture system to investigate cataract
formation presented by Daisy shoe thanks
for joining us and we hope to see you
then goodbye